Arising out of the peace and prosperity of
the post-war world, in the middle of the 20th
century Americans threw themselves into a
variety of weird fads, with goldfish swallowing,
pet rocks (see: How Did the Pet Rock Fad Start?),
streaking, dance marathons, and sea monkeys
(see What are Sea Monkeys?) among the most
popular.
One that received less attention internationally,
but whose participants and spectators ardently
loved, was the curious case of octopus wrestling.
At the time, the general perception of giant
octopuses was that they were fearsome predators
of the deep.
As such, wrestling one seemed the height of
manliness.
As for the developed sport itself, it was
pretty much like it sounds, involving men
hunting out an octopus’ lair and then wrangling
the cephalopod out and up to the surface by
hand.
That said, according to accounts from early
practitioners of the sport, it was inspired
by a much more bloody pastime- octopus hunting,
which was the subject of an apparently widely-read
story published in Modern Mechanix, “Octopus
Wrestling is My Hobby” (April 1949).
In the article, author Wilmon Menard describes
in great and brutal detail a hunting expedition
he took to the South Pacific, in which he
and his native guides found, caught and killed
octopuses, including one that Menard described
as “a huge monster with 25-foot tentacles.”
Per Menard, capturing an octopus first required
getting it sufficiently fearful, defensive
or curious to come out of its lair.
Once they got it to emerge, the octopus would
often go on the attack, wrapping its tentacles
around whatever it could grab, inevitably
something essential or delicate – like a
diver’s regulator or mask.
Menard reported the “huge monster” began
its attack by lashing at the men with its
tentacles, which they began to hack off with
knives.
Menard then states the octopus began “pulling
itself up the reef by its partly-severed tentacles.
. . then it started rolling toward us.”
Eventually the men were heroically able to
drive spears into its head to kill the fearsome
creature.
Menard also took the time to point out that,
at least according to him, an octopus would
make “a human-like moan” when it died…
So fast-forward about a decade later to Seattle,
Washington and the diving club, the Puget
Sound Mud Sharks, who also enjoyed tangling
with octopuses, in this case the Giant Pacific
variety (enteroctopus dofleini).
Unlike Menard, however, once they captured
one of the animals and took its measurements,
the diving club members just donated it (alive)
to aquariums in the area, or more often just
released it back into the wild after the fun
(for the humans) was over.
Holding what they called the World Octopus
Wrestling Championships at Titlow Beach in
the late 1950s and early 1960s, the rules
were simple: three-men teams dived looking
for octopuses in two categories: scuba gear
and free diving.
The former received one point per pound of
any octopus they caught, while the latter
free divers received two points per pound.
The octopuses caught typically ranged from
50-60 pounds (about 25 kg, though could be
as heavy as a little over twice that) and
usually measured from 7 to 12 feet across
(about 2-4 meters).
They were kept on shore in fish tanks while
they awaited weigh-ins and were later generally
released back into the water once the event
was over as previously noted.
One of the founders of the sport, Gary Keffler
(who incidentally was once Lloyd Bridges’
stunt double), described the “dangers”
of tangling with giant octopuses in a much
less exaggerated manner than Menard did in
his 1949 piece:
You had to be just a little bit careful about
them grabbing your mask or getting a hold
of your hose…they could crimple it – tighten
it up so air would be cut off a little bit…
Keffler also noted that, contrary to what
you might think, the Giant Pacific octopus,
despite being one of the world’s largest
octopuses, isn’t actually terribly strong,
certainly not enough to squeeze a person in
any damaging way, nor are their beaks of any
real concern.
He also stated that it wasn’t actually that
hard to pull lose from the tentacles if things
got a bit too dangerous, like if it ripped
out your air supply and you needed a little
break.
The hard part was simply coaxing the octopus
out of its den.
Apparently if it didn’t come out willingly,
it was somewhat difficult to pull its slippery
body out when it had all its arms suctioned
to the rocks.
At the height of the sport’s popularity
in 1964, more than 100 divers competed before
a crowd of about 5,000 spectators.
However, within a decade, people had moved
onto other hobbies.
Even the aforementioned co-founder of the
sport, Gary Keffler, would later state in
an interview about his retrospective thoughts
on wrestling octopus, “There’s no reason-
unless you were going to get them for food-
to harm them or take them.
So why bother hurting something that isn’t
hurting you?”
The shift in attitude was largely thanks to
the widespread perception of octopus as “dangerous
sea monsters” changing to the more accurate
label of “fascinating, mostly harmless (to
humans) animals.”
This switch was helped in no small part by
the 1971 Jacques Cousteau documentary Octopus,
Octopus (watch it here) which documented the
creatures in great detail, including their
relatively benign (to humans) nature.
Needless to say, the general public, and the
divers themselves, quickly lost interest,
starting to see octopus wrestling more as
animal cruelty than good fun and a fair fight.
And so it was that in 1976, the state mostly
outlawed the sport, making it illegal to “molest”
or “harass” an octopus, although it could
still be fished for food purposes, meaning
one could choose to capture octopus by hand
with intent to eat, if the individual in question
had an appropriate permit.
In fact, by 2010, octopuses in the waters
around Washington could only be harvested
without anything that would “penetrate or
mutilate the body.”
This brings us to one of the region’s last
publicly known octopus wrestlers.
For reasons not entirely clear, in 2012 then
19 year old Dylan Mayer was inspired to hunt
an octopus with nothing but his bare hands,
training for the event in his parent’s pool
with friends.
Once he deemed himself ready, he was able
to get a permit for such a hunt.
And so it was that on October 31, 2012, he
went into the water off Alki Beach to search
for his prey, which turned out to be a nine
foot Giant Pacific octopus that initially
retreated in its rock piling upon encountering
Mayer.
However, after continued harassment, Mayer
reported it exploded out at him with a vengeance,
simultaneously grabbing Mayer’s leg and
wrapping its tentacles all over his torso
and face.
At this point, Mayer stated the octopus pulled
the regulator out of his mouth.
Panicking a little, he punched the octopus
in the head and the fight was on.
The media reported it took approximately 25
minutes for Mayer to wrestle the octopus to
the surface, though if you read the accounts
of veteran octopus wrestlers or just watch
the previously linked Octopus, Octopus, this
seems a bit exaggerated.
As Jacques Cousteau himself notes (and demonstrates)
“matched in mid-water against a girl with
experience, even the largest octopus in the
world doesn’t stand a chance.”
So one has to wonder how much of this time
(if it really took that long at all) was simply
Mayer needing to stop at appropriate depths
for a while to allow the nitrogen to off-gas
from his system, rather than a major struggle,
as was often described in news reports.
Whatever the case, Mayer was successful at
bringing the octopus back to land, though
soon wished he wasn’t.
When a group of divers saw him emerge, “punching
an 80-pound octopus,” they were outraged.
Nevertheless, they were unable to stop him
from taking the octopus home, as he had the
proper permit and had captured it with his
bare hands with intent to eat it, making it
perfectly legal for him to do so.
Subsequently, when he got home, he cooked
and ate the animal.
But this is the age of social media and flash
internet mobs; so it’s unsurprising that
when the other divers, still aghast and having
taken photos of Mayer, posted them online,
the public outrage was palpable, with people
eventually tracking down the young man’s
personal details to share among the masses.
Thankfully for the embattled teenager, Mayer
was redeemed in the public eye in part by
showing up to a Washington Fish and Wildlife
Commission meeting with his parents and stating,
“I was the hunter.
I did not know that that place was so loved
by all the divers, or otherwise I would not
have done it…
I do agree with how that place should be off
limits [to octopus hunting], and it should
be clearly posted so that this mistake doesn’t
happen again.”
On top of that, the New York Times, among
others, pointed out the irony of some of the
same news outlets who were vilifying Mayer
one week singing the praises of a new restaurant,
Bar Sajor, in Pioneer square the next, including
giving rave reviews for the restaurant’s
Giant Pacific octopus salad…
And, indeed, they noted commercially caught
Giant Pacific octopus is popularly purchased
and consumed at many restaurants around Seattle
without any of the outrage that had been directed
at Mayer, who’d perfectly legally caught
and prepared his dinner himself.
Nevertheless, to address the public outrage
that emerged from Mayer’s hunting trip,
and to conserve specific popular diving sites,
the state designated seven Octopus Protection
Areas, more or less putting the final legal
nail in the mostly long-closed coffin of the
practice of wrestling Giant Pacific octopus
in the region.